the United States has announced its
formal withdrawal from the World Health
Organization u.s. President Donald Trump
threatened to leave the w-h-o and
permanently cut funding to the
organization back in May over
disagreements about how to respond to
the global coronavirus pandemic Trump
accuses the UN agency of quote pushing
Chinese misinformation although he had
praised China's handling of the outbreak
at the beginning of the year the US was
the largest financial contributor to the
whu-oh well for more now I'm joined on
the line by Professor Paula braveman
she's the director of the Center on
social disparities in health at the
University of California in San
Francisco thanks for being with us
professor now you are among 750 scholars
and health professionals who signed a
letter to Congress condemning the Trump
administration's decision to withdraw
from the w-h-o why do you think it's the
wrong move well I think isn't it if
Trump succeeds and that's not entirely
clear I must say but if he did succeed
with this it would represent a huge step
backward for Humanity I mean the United
Nations and its core agencies including
WH o rose from the ashes and the horror
of World War two with the Nazi Holocaust
and the atomic bomb and it was a
repudiation of hatred and brutality and
based on a recognition that either
humanity would fall further into the
abyss or people would cooperate and
collaborate with each other and even
support each other to achieve a better
life for everyone unfortunately the
current President of the United States
does not share these values but I do
think that most Americans do okay well
the WHI of course is concentrating on
global public health and Donald Trump is
not alone in criticizing the w-h-o s
handling if the corona virus pandemic
many say the organization was too slow
didn't give sufficient warning failed to
scrutinize what was happening in China
in short that the wh o--'s guilty of
gross negligence or these not valid
criticisms
I don't think that those urns are valid
criticisms which is not to say that
things could not have been done better
but I would feel pretty comfortable
venturing to say that compared with
Trump's handling of the pandemic in the
US the WH o I think would come out
looking far more adequate and that
really what many of us think that he's
trying to do with this move is it he's
he's looking for a scapegoat to hide his
own incompetence his dereliction of duty
and his total lack of compassion or
empathy from the kovat pandemic I wanted
to focus on the w-h-o itself do you not
agree that the wh o needs to be reformed
I agree with the WH o needs to be
reformed but it is not a basket case and
and there's much that's good there and
the argument that that an institution
needs to be reformed is not an argument
for destroying it and I don't think
anyone has provided evidence that would
lead us to believe that the WH o should
be destroyed should not exist at all
professor thank you very much for
talking with us that was professor Paula
braveman she's director of the center
and social disparities in health at the
University of California San Francisco
my pleasure now the United States
remains the country hardest hit by the
corona virus and it's getting worse
despite sharp rises in Nuuk over 19
cases across the country many areas are
going ahead with reopening that includes
the southern state of Georgia or around
a thousand people are testing positive
each day but officials there are easing
restrictions intended to control the
pandemic as public life resumes African
Americans are among those facing the
greatest risk
things look like they're getting back to
normal at Lake Allatoona just 20 miles
northeast of Georgia's capital Atlanta a
lot of boaters are back on the water and
nobody's wearing a mask in downtown
Atlanta and across the entire state a
growing number of shops and restaurants
are reopening Georgia is back in
business and at work by order of the
governor but not so fast decap County
Atlanta a food drive a fairly common
sight these days we're told that
predominantly effluent african-americans
live here
however today long lines of cars fill
the parking lot again for a box of
vegetables and a bag of frozen chicken
breasts one her current household
this is John Beals he's a chef and used
to have a thriving catering business
then Kovac nineteen hit a corner selling
barbecue Beale says the state's decision
to loosen restrictions early and widely
means he can work and feed his family
but of course he knows about the
potential health risks and it makes him
feel uneasy with no cure it's like
sending people out to just kind of see
what happens in so many words like
guinea pigs African Americans living in
Atlanta's historically underprivileged
communities have suffered the most from
the Kovach 19 lockdown and also from
what many say was a hasty reopening of
the state they work low paying jobs live
in so-called food deserts with no access
to healthy nutrition let alone quality
health care or education yet they're
often so-called frontline workers with
no other options for work
the coronavirus death rate of black
americans is roughly 2.5 times higher
than that of might and asian americans
and twice as high as the death rate for
Latinos we meet pastor Anthony motely he
says by reopening the state for business
too quickly
the governor willfully put primarily
African American lives in danger what
we're doing is African American leaders
and pastors we're encouraging our people
to social distance
shelter-in-place use masks the pastor
says president rhombus ultimately to
blame for ignoring the disproportionate
number of African Americans dying from
covert 19 across the country
Mowgli's convinced Trump will pay a
heavy price for this at the ballot boxes
in the presidential elections come this
November for now he wants his
congregation to stay home urging them
not to go to work or even come to church